Hủ hàng không Việt Nam vừa đến gỡ các hàng không không trong nước vụ Việt Nam L-i,
về JT, MENBOO Airways, BASIFIC L-i và VHVL-i xem sẽ tâm tình sức khai thác chuyến bay đêm từ Hanoi,
thành phố chiming đến bình định và ngược lại trong giai đoạn từ thằng sau đến thằng chiến năm 2019.
Độ Thai này, nhằm đáp ứng yêu cầu đi lại tăng cao trong mộ suy lịch kẻ,
đồng thời phục vụ chủ sức kiện văn hóa, thế thao và suy lịch quy mô lớn được tổ chức tại bình định trong phế ra này.
Trước đó, bị bán nhân dân tình bình định đã có văn bản đến gỡ tăng kưởng các chuyến bay đêm đến
cả hàng khô vụ các nhằm tạo điều kiện thật lời cho dù khách.
Tình bình định sự kiến tổ chức nhiều sự kiện lớn, nhé, chối hoạt động dù lịch kẻ hai nghỉ khu chăm hai mil năm,
giải trảy via de Express Marathon Quyen nhân, cuộc thi hoa hủ và nằm vương xương mẫu thiện hình thế giới.
Giải vô định có cuộc chuyến tòan khuốc lần thứ 8 mi tư, giải vô định bóng dù chế ba nhìn ba quốc gia và các hoạt động văn hóa, thế thao khá.
Bíng tăng chuyến bay đêm được ki vọng có phần bảo đam như cầu và tải hàng không.
Túc đầy phát triển dù lịch và kinh tế địa phương trong buộc cao điểm.